let's talk about American Gods this is
the new show that you're doing on Starz
and I can't begin to summarize the plot
it is a fascinating show but it's not
it's unlike any show I've seen before
it's very different best way I can
explain it to y'all is it's four worlds
coming together it's based on the great
Neil Gaiman book the American Gods we
have the old gods like Easter my
character and the new gods like media
and tech noble and how it all works
together and I think they've done an
incredible incredible job of making old
versus new also it begs the question and
this is kind of deep but how far are
willing to go with our world today you
know we change so all the time right and
how far we willing to go what is our
personal boundary I remember when
Twitter happened I thought I've got to
know if I'm gonna get on board here
Witter
you know tweet tweet but now I'm
obsessed so we'll see but I just I'm
very proud to be in it and my characters
introduced and the last episode and it's
Easter and the goddess of the earth
you're it's perfect it's a great role
for you got it you really are you you're
the goddess of Easter fertility and I
like that it's Easter with sort of a
sexy gleam in your eye
she's got a little she's got a little
mad that Jesus has decided to resurrect
on her special day but if
but it's but I like it because I'm I am
a Christian person so I I look at I also
in you know I don't judge other people
for their belief so I look at a lot of
different beliefs and this this show is
so fascinating and I just hope people
watch it I think they're watching it it
opened a Sunday night while I was
onstage at Boston
you